la fédération canadienne de l'entreprise
indépendante affirme que plus de la
moitié des pme comptent soumettre une
demande de subvention salariale avec
nous jasmin guénette vice président des
affaires nationales de la fcei à ottawa
monsieur gainey bonsoir oui bon secours
est-ce que ce programme de subventions
salariales répond aux besoins aux
attentes des pme mais ça répond à un peu
plus la moitié d'entre elles qui ont
indiqué qu'elle souhaitait appliquer les
applications sont en ligne à partir
d'aujourd'hui est donc on veut plus déjà
les midis d'entreprise au pays sous les
applications et donc pour un peu plus de
la moitié des pme canadiennes c'est un
programme qui est qui est important par
contre pour certains noms d'entreprises
c'est un programme qui ne convient pas
pour à peu près le quart des des pme
croyants mais pour le camp des pme
canadiennes
c'est simplement parce qu'elles ne sont
pas éligibles
elle voudrait appliquer ou brian
voudrait avoir droit à ces subventions
salariales là mais qu'elles ne peuvent
pas démontré une baisse de revenus de 30
% par exemple peut-être qu'elles ont une
baisse de revenus de 20% seulement et
donc elles ne peuvent pas appliquer puis
pour un certain nombre d'entreprises
pour le tiers environ des pme partout au
pays bas elle le programme arrive un peu
tard c'est à dire qu'elle est mise à
pied ont déjà été faites c'est un peu un
peu compliqué de revenir en arrière et
surtout pour les entreprises qui
génèrent peu ou pas de revenus parce que
parce qu'elles sont fermés on se
demandait à ce moment ci ce qui ce
programme là est vraiment fait pour pour
aider ces entreprises en même temps
ferrer trop donc dans un sens les
entreprises peuvent emprunter de
l'argent il ya le prêt sans intérêt
jusqu'à 40000 dollars pour couvrir la
période jusqu'à temps qu'on touche les
sommes seraient il ya le prix de 40
mille dollars encore et encore une fois
en priant où il ya de très nombreux
people et plusieurs pme ne sont pas
éligibles en raison de ces critères leur
ai donc les problèmes qui ont été
annoncées jusqu'à maintenant sont
importants pour un très grand nombre de
pme se sont déployés qui est bon pour
les élever la même chose pour le
programme qui a été annoncé la semaine
dernière sur l'aide au logement
cependant il ya beaucoup de critères ce
qui hélas souvent un très grand nombre
de pme non éligible et le présent que
vous mentionnez c'est un autre exemple
où il ya beaucoup de guitare et fait en
sorte qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui voudraient se
prévaloir de spoiler auquel n'est pas
fait mais il ya la subvention salariale
il ya le prêt à 40000 dollars sans
intérêt il ya l'aide d'urgence aux
loyers commerciaux
je présume qu'on couvre la majorité des
entreprises qui peuvent avoir un soutien
du gouvernement à ce concours
effectivement beaucoup de terre c'est à
dire que on a fait l'annoncé pour les
subventions salariales déjà un certain
temps on peut aujourd'hui sur les
applications les premiers montent à deux
lettres envoyées au tour du 5 certes
mais on a des prières pour aider aux
liquidités et on a ce programmeur pour
l'aide au logement donc on essaie de
couvrir l'ensemble de deux situations
auxquelles font face les pme encore une
fois vous parlez de l'aide au logement
pour les commerciaux oui exactement
pour les loyers commerciaux pour y avoir
droit
les entreprises doivent démontrer une
base de revenus
de soixante dix pour ça et seulement 40
% des pme ont pouvoir démontrer ces
baisses de revenus de 70 pour ça et donc
ça laisse un très grand nombre de pme
qui n'ont pas accès à ce programme dont
je me comprends monsieur guénette mais
en même temps on va pas aider des
entreprises qui n'ont pas besoin de l'un
des dossiers on a besoin de se faire
payer son loyer commercial c'est parce
qu'on a vraiment perdu beaucoup d'argent
vous avez raison cependant des
entreprises que les baisses de revenus
de 50 mille dollars de 50 pour sa part
dont ils né et non en baisse de revenus
de 70 pour ça ces entreprises ont eux
aussi pourraient certainement avoir
besoin d'un bon niveau de ses loyers là
mais faut reconnaître que les besoins de
main met en place plusieurs programmes
c'est pas évident de faire des
programmes et des politiques publiques
aussi rapidement et on reconnaît les
efforts qui sont mis par les frais râpé
lieberman a de tabac le gouvernement
fédéral et plusieurs entreprises qui
peuvent avoir un soutien présentement
seulement pour la subvention salariale
odyssey d'entrée de jeu c'est un peu
plus de la moitié des pme est utile pour
appliquer et donc c'est quand même des
problèmes qui sont importants et la
subvention salariale pour le rappeler
c'est quand même 75 % du ca va étudier
souvent interminables monsieur guénette
excusez moi c'est parce qu'il reste
quelques secondes
est ce que vous êtes d'avis qu'il faut
accélérer la réouverture de l'économie
je pense qu'on est rendu à avoir une
conversation sérieuse sur la réouverture
de l'économie et puis on est là on est
d'avis que c'est ça doit se faire en
collaboration avec avec les
propriétaires les chefs d'entreprise
pour s'assurer qu'à la fois on respecte
les critères de santé publique est aussi
con permettre aux entreprises de générer
des revenus de de retrouver leur
clientèle pour s'assurer qu'on reparle
économies sur le banc
bien merci beaucoup monsieur gainey
merci bien ça fait plaisir